have you noticed anything strange about
Mass Effect Andromeda animations yep me
too well despite the criticism Bioware
has announced that the game's day one
patch will not include any improvements
to the animations or character models
I'm Matt this is a game spot news update
and make sure to LIKE and subscribe to
be the first to know if and when
Andromeda will see improvements
Andromeda lead designer ian fraser told
a fan on Twitter that the ship is sailed
on character model improvements being
included in the day one patch this makes
sense since the day one updates ship has
literally sailed as it's included in the
now playable EA in origin access early
trials Frasier did say that there will
be further patches but what goes into
them exactly is still under discussion
Mass Effect Andromeda has received quite
a bit of criticism since the early
trials launched and most of it has been
directed at the game's animations and
facial models in particular while
there's no word on when our if these
will be fixed Frasier did say that bar
where is looking to add new skin tones
to the character creator and investigate
issues with the sound and multiplayer
it's a little too early for gamespot's
review of Andromeda but you can hear our
frustrating early impressions in the
latest episode of the lobby
[Music]